قد تبدو حياه هذه العائله هادئه للوهله
الاولى ولكن ما مر به توم وزوجته كيري
وابنتهما ايميلي لم يكن هادئا على الاطلاق
فهذه العائله الصغيره لم تكن على درايه
بالحرب الدائره في جسد الطفله الصغيره
ايملي قبل اربعه اعوام اتذكر عندما دخل
طبيب الاطفال ونظر اليه وقال ببطء وهدوء
يبدو ان ابنتك لديها سرطان بالدم عندها
انفصلت عن العالم وكنت امل ان يكون الامر
كابوسا قد استيقظ منه في اي
لحظه وقد شخص الاطباء حاله ايميلي
باصابتها بنوع حاد من سرطان الدم او ما
يتعارف عليه باسم لوكيميا الدم ورغم ان
التقارير تفيد بامكانيه شفاء ما نسبته
85% من الاطفال المصابين بسرطان الدم الا
ان الوضع لم يكن يبشر بالخير بالنسبه
لاميلي التي كانت تبلغ حينها اربعه اعوام
ويقول والدها انها توقفت عن التنفس لفتره
خلال وجودها في المستشفى وهي اللحظه
الخطره ذاتها التي تكررت غير مره بعد ذلك
بدات ايملي اولى جلسات علاجها الكيماوي
والذي استمر مده 16 شهرا وبعد ذلك تلقت
العائله انباء سيئه مجددا عام
2011 اخبرنا الاطباء بان حاله املي ساءت
بشكل كبير بعد العلاج الكيماوي وكان وقع
ذلك حينها اصعب من السماع باصابتها
بالسرطان لاننا شعرنا بان اتخذنا الخطوات
الصحيحه لتتحسن حالتها ورغم كل هذا لم
يتحقق ذلك خضعت ايميلي بعدها لجلسه اخرى
من العلاج الكيماوي لكن النتيجه تكررت
مجددا وكان السرطان يعود بقوه اكبر في كل
مره بدا السباق مع الزمن للحفاظ على حياه
الفتاه لذا قررت العائلات تجربه خيار جديد
وبدا يعود الى قلوبهم من جديد بعد الخضوع
لدراسه تجريبيه للعلاج المناعي في مستشفى
الاطفال بفيلادلفيا
وهذا الاسلوب يعتمد على تزويد المريض
بخلايا سليمه تحفز جهاز المناعه لديه
لتقوم بدورها في دفع خلايا الدم البيضاء
للقضاء ذاتيا على السرطان كانت ايملي اول
مريضه تخضع لتجربه ما توصل له الاطباء في
مستشفى فيلادلفيا والدراسات التي استغرقت
عده سنوات جرى خلالها خضوع ثلاثه بالغين
للتجربه حينها وظهرت نتائج ايجابيه على
حالتهم الصحيه ولكن في حاله ايميلي كانت
مخاوف الاطباء منبثقه من نوع لوكيميا الدم
لديها والذي يختلف عما يصيب عاده الشخص
البالغ وازداد الامر صعوبه بالنسبه
للاطباء بسبب عدم وجود تجارب ونتائج يمكن
العوده اليها بهدف المقارنه مع حاله
ايميلي عند بدء تجربه العلاج المقترح ورغم
ذلك قرر الاهل المضي قدما في التجربه اذ
لم يكن لديهم خيارات اخرى لانقاذ طفلتهم
ايميلي لوحظ بعض التحسن على ايميلي بعد
اول حقنه من الخلايا لكن جسدها شهد
مضاعفات بعد الحقنه الثالثه اذ ارتفعت
حرارتها وانخفض ضغط دمها وبدات تعاني من
فشل في رئتيها اكتشف الاطباء المشرفون على
حالتها ان خلايا الدم بعد مهاجمتها
للسرطان بدات بافراز بروتين توجه للقضاء
على الاعضاء الداخليه لجسد ايميلي عندها
تمكن الاطباء من ايجاد طريقه للقضاء على
ذلك البروتين لكن ايملي دخلت في حاله
غيبوبه وبقيت في قسم العنايه المركزه
لاسبوعين صارع فيها جسدها للبقاء على قيد
الحياه واستيقظت ايملي يوم عيد ميلادها
السابع ليكتشف الاطباء بعد اجراء فحوصات
اضافيه بان السرطان اختفى من جسدها كليا
العلاج لا يزال في مراحله الاوليه ويامل
الاطباء بان يمتد الى مراكز اخرى حول
العالم حيث يقول القائمون على البحث ان
حقن الاطفال بالاجسام المضاده يمكنه ان
يخزن معلومات الشفاء في ذاكره خلاياهم
لمحاربه اي خلايا سرطانيه يمكن ان تظهر في
اجسادهم
مستقبلا عوده السرطان للنمو يشكل هاجسا
لدى المرضى الذين شفوا منه لكن ايملي
تحتفل الان بمرور عامين على خلو جسدها من
المرض الخبيث وها هي تحمل لافته تقول فيها
جسد خال من السرطان منذ عامين وقد اشترطت
ايملي على والدتها بان تحمل اللافته ذاتها
عند مرور 50 عاما على شفاء
hin